quand votre fille reconnaît pas sa mère
c'est c'est là qu'on prend conscience à
quel point sites affectés
josy dufresne une fille de 16 ans sophie
en décembre dernier elle se présente
presque inconsciente à l'urgence
puis elle passe les trois jours suivants
d'un coma séjour à l'hôpital non sophie
est atteinte de diabète de type 1
mais l'ignorait depuis plusieurs
semaines son corps lui envoyer des
signaux de détresse qu'elle ne
reconnaissait pas avant qu'on arrive à
l'hôtel avant james h j'avais pour
gossip il ya mes amis et mon entourage
beaucoup personnes connaisseurs cette
grève complications liées au diabète non
traité un nom l'acidocétose diabétique
est-ce que c'est waouh c'est maman qui
fait à guissény sétois vivre avec le
diabète de type 1 exige de vérifier
régulièrement son taux de sucre et de
s'injecter de l'insuline plusieurs fois
par jour l'un celui est essentiel pour
contrôler le sucre dans l'organisme
quand l'institut les n'est pas présent
dans le camp des deux-tiers par une
accumulation de sucre dans l'organisme
et ce à cause d'une accumulation de cet
homme qui eux sont assis donc ça
intoxiquent l'organisme à cause que le
temps devient acide
lorsqu'un enfant ignorent qu'ils
souffrent du diabète il va
progressivement s'intoxiquer sans savoir
les agnostiques est trop tard c'est là
que les acides commencent à s'accumuler
qu'on développe la complication et qui
est une complication possiblement
mortels et que l'on doit admettre
l'enfant la plupart du temps aux soins
intensifs pendant plusieurs jours pour
diminuer la cites dans le temps et
corrigée la cité aussitôt et éthiques
sophie n'est pas la seule dans son cas
une étude démontre que sur les 4000
jeunes atteints de diabète au québec 30%
ont souffert des six dos et aux
diabétiques et que ce nombre est en
hausse constante
la solution apprendre à reconnaître les
principaux symptômes du diabète juvénile
besoin fréquent d'uriner soif anormal
perte de poids et c'est ce que je
réalise avec leur accueil c'est
ça serait bien qu'on se conçoit avec
qu'on soit avisé c'est pas un reproche
aux professionnels mais de dire c'est
quelque chose qui est pas connu qu'on
connaissait pas du tout peut-être de
s'être fait poser la question avez vous
vérifié pour le diabète ça pourrait être
une cause et la prévention ça fonctionne
disent les spécialistes
on sait que des pays comme la finlande
par exemple ils ont une incidence très
élevé de diabète de type 1 est donc la
population est très au courant et dans
ces pays-là l'incidence de dias da
société aux diabétiques est beaucoup
plus basse ici normand grondin radio
canada montréal